meanwhile in just two days border patrol
agents in the del rio sector have
rescued two five-year-old girls trying
to cross the border alone in two
separate incidents why is this not a
bigger story but as the crisis at our
own southern border grows president
biden's deploying troops to protect
ukraine's border so to speak or at least
nato's border near the ukraine arizona
gubernatorial candidate steve gainer
writes this
i am in sense that mr biden is sending
american soldiers and tax dollars to
shore up the ukrainian border while
arizona and our fellow border states are
subject to a full-scale invasion caused
by his policy he joins us now uh
steve
what made you equate the two
in your column on fox news
well
the ukrainian border is something that
joe biden is paying attention to
putting american resources at risk it's
a potential invasion but what we have in
arizona is an actual invasion we have
people pouring across the border
drugs trafficking
it's it's outrageous and he's doing
nothing and these unaccompanied minors
just walk through if this was two year a
year a half ago this would be how could
president trump have a policy that
allows children to be caught alone at
the border but instead it doesn't even
make the radar on other channels
well it's making the radar in arizona we
know what's going on here
and it's intolerable
we know people are coming across
every day when i visited the border
there were hundreds of people waiting
for the border patrol to pick them up
it's as if the border patrol is now uber
taking people from the border right to
the airports and flying them all over
the country i know you want to be uh the
next governor uh of arizona one thing is
also clear your senators are m.i.a as
bold as senator cinema is she never
talks about the border i don't know if
mark kelly even wants to be noticed on
surveillance video so why don't they
care is it about their party or about
the country
brian i think this is intentional
they're flooding our country with people
who are illegal but at the same time
people are coming into our country who
really i think mean us no good it's a
national security issue as well as an
issue in arizona we have escalating
crime overdoses all over the place and
it's it's terrible in terms of arizona
we put a lot of focus on texas
why haven't the national guard been
mobilized in arizona like the national
guard has been mobilized
in texas
i believe the guard has been mobilized
here to some degree but
we're overmatched
the sheriff's departments and uh and
border patrol itself
dps they're overwhelmed by the number of
people who are coming across
steve brian i would ask you yes just
real quick the vice president was asked
about this a few days ago and she said
the first thing we did
as an administration is offer
immigration reform uh and nobody took it
up in congress what's your answer to
that
the first thing they did is overturn the
trump administration policies keeping
people on the other side of the border
and gave the cartels an engraved
invitation to just bring people in and
that's what they're doing
so i would ask your audience go to my
website gainerforgovernor.com
we can use all the help we can get here
in arizona yeah i mean you obviously
could and when you talk about other
nationalities are you seeing other than
central america and south america who
are you seeing
yes we've seen people from uzbekistan
pakistan and countries in the middle
east it's clear to me when i visited the
border there are a lot of
spanish-speaking people
no mexicans central american and cubans
but there are people from other parts of
the world that don't belong here
cost us a ton of money a lot in security
and peace of mind uh steve gainer thanks
so much
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now